i remember i was driving back home and i
got this text and it said hey we closed
two sales today and there had been four
people who had walked into the business
and i had to pull over to the side of
the road because i was i got so
emotional i got teary because it was the
first time that someone else had ever
sold something besides me and so that
was the first moment when i realized
that like this could become a business
that did not require me and if you don't
know who i am my name is alex ramose i
own acquisition.com it's a portfolio of
companies that now does about 85 million
a year and i have nothing to sell you
and the reason for this video is i want
to walk you through one of the most
important steps which is how do you hire
excellent salespeople and how do you
recognize great sales people and so now
i've built i can't tell you the amount
of team like sales teams that we've now
now built up but i can tell you
this video is going to be specifically
about recognizing talent and so um a
couple quick frameworks that i want to
go through number one when i started in
this business i took every single sale
and it was because i was so afraid that
somebody would waste the opportunity so
if you have that fear i understand where
you're coming from second
when i had my first sale that was not me
i i just had this emotional breakdown so
i was like oh my god this could actually
happen and i promise you if you haven't
had it happen yet you will when it does
because you realize that this business
can actually work without you and other
people can make it rain too right and
then i'll tell you a quick story that'll
illustrate the next point that i'm going
to make so as i you know hired some
sales people now that first salesperson
were they exceptional no but they were
able to get the job done later on i had
my first kind of like killer um and his
name was mauro negretti and he uh he
came in
i don't know a year or two into the
business a year into the business and he
so quickly was able to assume the sales
role and to show you how laughable this
is
he started and
i was about to start training him and
some lady walked in the door
and i was like hey man like i can take
he's like no i'm good he's like go do
your thing he's like finish nutrition
accountability okay i'll figure it out
and he ended up closing this first lady
who walked in the door for a paid in
full
and i remember walking in like
completely dumbstruck i was like he
didn't even know what the pitch was
but she walked out giggling happy so
excited to start and
what that
moment taught me was that
it is good to train sales people but
it's better to take great sales people
and then just
point them in a direction and so this
has informed a lot of the thinking that
i have around talent in general and i'll
tell you a couple of frameworks that
have informed this but like if you look
at harvard harvard doesn't produce the
smartest people
they select the smartest people and then
they put
smart uh professors in front of them but
like the base level of intelligence of
everyone who's at harvard is already
exceptionally high and so like even if
the teachers at harvard were not
exceptional the students are and they
would be successful independent of that
because their selection is so ridiculous
right and so if we can think about our
own companies that way and especially if
you're in the service business like look
at the biggest service companies out
there like look at mckinsey look at bain
look at bcg look at basically a lot of
the finance world is or service based
businesses a lot of times right and
they're able to do that because they
create such a pool to select from that
they are able to skim for the best
talent right i heard this uh quote from
uh esther cathy who's the founder of
chick-fil-a you win the championship in
the draft and so it was such a belief
that they had about picking the right
people even more so than training and i
would say that i have moved in that
direction of a little bit more nature
than nurture when it comes to
roles specifically sales especially
there are certain characteristics about
building rapport about having certain
you know dynamics or energy whatever you
want to say that like mar negrete when
he walked in he had all of these things
and he didn't even know the pitch but he
won that sale off of just pure rapport
and so if i'm going to allocate the same
level of time to training somebody i
might as well start with somebody who
has a much higher base because i could
spend 10 hours to take someone from a
two to a four and a half or i could
spend the same 10 hours taking someone
from a six to a nine and the thing is
i'm also going to get more bang for my
buck in terms of my hours of training
with somebody who has a natural
proclivity for selling compared to
somebody who does not what's interesting
about this and this is just like my
observation is that you just have to be
willing to talk to more people in the uh
recruiting process i will say like from
a recruiting standpoint there's there's
two kind of things to look out for if
you're if you're if you cannot pay
super handsomely based on your price
points which you need to maybe fix later
but like if you can't pay super well for
the sales person then you need to look
harder and you'll need to interview more
people and you'll need to probably run
ads and use your network if you can pay
well the best sales people are already
employed and so it comes down to
recruiting those sales people from other
sales jobs ideally from companies just
like yours so that they already know a
lot of the things coming into it so it
decreases the ramp up time for them
because all we're really doing is
swapping products and the actual sales
cycle the type of sale is it a
transactional sales a long sale is it a
software sale is it a coaching program
so whatever it is right there's so few
variables that we're changing that they
can immediately jump and go which also
allows you to make a judgment on their
proficiency faster and so as a quick
side note to this because this is
something that i've given a lot of
thought if you look at the top sales
people and sales trainers and this is
going to drive point drive home the
point that i was making earlier about it
being
much of it being born all right is that
if you look at the top people who are in
the space you look at jordan belfort
right you look at bradley you look at um
and some people would would say me
intern from a selling perspective all
the guys that i know who have taught
sales were exceptional sales people day
one bradley started selling cars when he
was 18 years old was the top salesman at
18 years old when he started and he was
like i just found something i was really
good at jordan belford talks about how
he didn't know how to train anybody in
his book and then all of a sudden he for
the first time ever wrote out a
framework to explain the straight line
sale system which became his book and
all that kind of stuff but he up to that
point it was just what he naturally
did right and i can tell you in my
instance as well i'd already closed
thousands of deals before i even
consumed my first sales training and so
like i do think that if we are selecting
sales people i think it's much more
about selection than it is about
training the training is to remind them
how good they are not necessarily to
make them good all right and this is
something that has shifted over time for
me specifically now if you're like well
i suck at sales you can absolutely put
way more time into yourself than a
business would reasonably put into an
employee all right like you have you all
the time so you can train you in all
your off hours and you're spending your
own time to invest in yourself but from
a return on investment perspective it's
the cost of finding a good salesperson
compared to the cost of training a bad
or mediocre salesperson is significantly
lower it's much easier to find the right
people than it is to take somebody and
then make such a crazy extensive
training unless your entire model is we
just take on every single person who
walks in the door like 24-hour fitness
has this model they take on anybody who
has a pulse and then they put them
through a ridiculous culling process and
then 10 of people make it in the first
90 days and may the arms be ever in your
right that's their process and then
those people know how to sell and so
they just make ridiculous requirements
that almost no one can meet except for
exceptional sales people and they they
let that they have obviously training
systems and whatnot but for the most
part it's teaching them about their
process and just having old sales people
explain to new sales people some of the
tips and tricks that have just like made
them better rather than teaching the
fundamentals of selling and so back to
you if you're somebody who's not good at
sales that's okay you get there through
practice and repetition but in terms of
like you
have to get good at it because it is
like it is core to running a business
especially a small business is learning
how to close right and so if you take
time to learn it it's okay it's a skill
that you're going to add in your arsenal
and then it'll allow you to recognize
good sales people in the future but you
can't spend a year trying to train
somebody who's not good you can spend a
year trying to train you right and
that's the difference when we're
selecting for exceptional sales people
which is what i'm saying selecting for
exceptional sales people if you pay less
you have to talk to more people to find
them and then you have to have low
tolerance in terms of how quickly they
make a sale and i would say for us if
somebody doesn't close a deal in the
first sales cycle meaning like depending
on the the length of the transaction uh
like some people you know there's all
transactional sales some people might be
a two-week sales cycler or a one-month
sales cycle depending on what you're
selling if someone has done a full sale
cycle and they haven't closed the deal i
already know that they're not a killer
because every single killer i've ever
had closes deals in their first cycle
just like mario getty like i said
earlier the killers come in and start
killing and then they just get better at
killing with the tweaks and the
trainings that we have the guys who
don't do that are the ones that are like
no give me another shot i like i just
gotta learn like you know blah blah blah
and the thing is it's like it just drags
on an inevitable consequence and so
right now if you have somebody on your
team and you've been in that dragging it
on and they're like just barely good
enough to stay on the team and every
single quarter you're like are we gonna
let go of this guy i don't know he's not
like a winner but like i guess we kind
of need him to keep putting some numbers
up if you get rid of the people who are
dragging the team down the culture of
the team will improve and i promise you
whenever you cut the bottom the top
moves up right and then it also will set
the new bar for the person who comes in
it's like this is how a world-class team
operates are you up for this and the
thing is is the tighter and the higher
that team is the faster they'll point
the person out if they don't fit or
they'll immediately accept and glob in
the person they'll become part of the
unit so if you're looking for sales
people and you're looking to scale the
sales team the best sales people are
born in my opinion not made we can
select for those people either through
recruiting them directly from people who
have very similar businesses to us or we
have to interview many more people and
the feeling you get in that tingle when
you're like oh god i really have to have
this guy that's when you hire not when
you're like i mean i guess this guy
could do the job can't do that it's not
gonna work and then on the flip side
once that person is in if they haven't
closed the deal on that first cycle the
longer i've been doing business the
shorter my tolerance for somebody not
being exceptional is because every
person that has been exceptional i know
immediately and so i just have less and
less time where i think maybe they'll
turn it around maybe some more training
we'll get them there when it's when a
lot of times you win the draft on the
pick and so thank you guys appreciate it
if you're new to mozy nation welcome and
i'll see you guys in the next video bye